the governor who just won't go away
that's the topic for tonight's angle
John Kasich has been a headline of a
Sunday show guest for now what 17 times
since Trump's inauguration and he used
his latest Sunday Show outing yesterday
to convene a gun-control talking group
but I want to do is I want to get a
group of reasonable people pro-gun
people and those who favor limits on gun
ownership and I want to put him in a
room and see if we can find some common
ground fascinating and a month ago he
spent another Sunday morning trashing
president Trump's trade in immigration
policies the Republican Party cannot be
anti trade the Republican Party can't be
anti-immigrant why does Kasich think his
voice is wanted in the current political
environment
oh yeah he's still governor of Ohio but
he has zero constituency in the party in
the grass roots and remember he wouldn't
even attend the Republican convention in
his home state oh no I don't know if
Kasich felt like it was just too
humiliated to show his face in Cleveland
and don't you hate a sore loser even
Detroit Mayor Coleman young welcomed the
GOP to the city of Detroit in 1980 and
he was a Democrat and though Kasich is a
total washout nationally let's face it
it's uncharitable to say but he is he's
considering running in 2020 on something
called a unity ticket with Democrat
Governor John Hickenlooper of Colorado
that'll work
in his commentary you can hear Kasich
simmering disdain for the party that so
roundly rejected him and his contempt
for President Trump is now legendary
perhaps I was thinking back on this I
think it's one debate moment perhaps
from October of 2015 that really stuck
in his craw let's watch this is the man
that was a managing general partner at
Lehman Brothers when it went down the
tubes
and almost took every one of us with us
including Ben and myself because I was
there and I watched what happened hmm
that's done and though he's long denied
his personal bitterness
anything to do with this grudge against
Trump I noticed believe it at this point
John Kasich can go on all the sunday
shows he likes and reporters will
continue to celebrate him as the uber
coolest never Trump er of them all but
after all the bluster the photo shoots
in the camera time the greenroom time
John Kasich is where he was at the end
of the primary season he's a man with
enormous ambition and just minimal
support just a little bit we may not
know where Kasich is headed but boy do
we know where he came from
do you remember what his father did well
let's start off with my father being a
mailman well Megan my father was a
mailman and my father was the mailman
they called him John the mailman like my
dad the mailman John the mailman and I
got to tell you my father carried mail
on his back I like mail man and speaking
of mail this will soon be landing in the
mailboxes of Unfortunate GQ subscribers
everywhere in there man of the year
edition gentleman's quarterly has named
Colin Kaepernick citizen of the Year the
man who started the NFL kneeling
epidemic during the national anthem the
man who inspired his fellow players to
break faith with their audience the man
who's responsible for the league losing
millions and merchandising and tickets
and viewers is being hailed by a men's
fashion magazine as an exemplary citizen
if you're looking for exemplary citizens
I have a few how about Steven Willeford
the Texas man who confronted in pursued
that church shooter in Sutherland
Springs or how about Houston Texans star
JJ Watt he raised 37 million dollars for
Hurricane Harvey victims and by the way
GQ also named Stephen Colbert the bad
hombre of the year well I suppose if you
hate president Trump stage protests and
complain well you're instantly something
of the year at GQ the good news is
Kaepernick and Colbert made our year and
cut as hot as well not sure if they're
gonna be celebrating this honor though
and that's the angle